[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent le Sénat lance une commission
d'enquête sur l'électricité en 2022 la
France grande exportatrice d'électricité
depuis des décennies grâce au nucléaire
s'est trouvé fort dépourvu quand l'hiver
fut venu alors que l'approvisionnement
n'était plus un problème depuis les
années 70 nous avons vu ressurgir
l'impensable des risques de BL et des
injonctions au rationnement encore
aujourd'hui les défis restent nombreux
de quelle manière gérer les hausses des
prix de l'énergie comment faire face à
l'augmentation des besoins en
électricité tout en relevant les défis
de la transition
énergétique comment préserver notre
indépendance
industrielle pour tenter d'y voir plus
clair et s'assurer de la pertinence de
nos choix de politique énergétique en
particulier en matière d'électricité le
Sénat a constitué une commission
d'enquête sur la production la
consommation et le prix de l'électricité
aux horizons 2035 et
2050 présidé par Franck montaoger avec
Vincent de lae comme rapporteur elle
s'est réunie le 18 janvier 2024 pour
constituer son bureau et lancer ses
travaux alors que la commission
d'enquête de l'Assemblée nationale
s'était attachée à rechercher les
raisons de la crise actuelle de
l'électricité celle du Sénat centrera
ses travaux sur le présent et l'avenir
du système électrique si les sénateurs
examineront dans quelle mesure les
propositions des députés ont été suivis
des faits la commission enquêtera sur
quatre autres thèmes elle s'intéressera
tout d'abord à la réalité et à la
fiabilité des prévisions de consommation
d'énergie en particulier d'électricité
elle examinera ensuite si l'évolution
des capacité de production et
d'acheminement de l'électricité apparaît
en adéquation avec les prévisions de
consommation les sénateurs se pencheront
également sur le marché européen de
l'électricité et le mécanisme de
formation des prix de ce secteur enfin
ils étudieront les aides qui peuvent
permettre aux consommateurs de faire
face aux évolutions de prix la
commission d'enquête achèvera ses
travaux au plus tard le 17 juillet
2024 pour suivre ces travaux rendez-vous
sur le site internet du
Sénat